will the new seasons of Annamayya what
about many of us will have to go about
picking what is and even worth watching
and it's common that you may feel
overwhelmed taking a look at all these
new shows and the articles I ran into
this don't tell you the really important
information you need to know when diving
into seasonal anime but have no fear
this is why I've compiled the actual
seasonal guide every fan needs to know
now the first thing you'll want to do is
ignore the seasonal charts and get
yourself on my anime list kids to your
analysts account these are very useful
free sites where the main functionality
is being able to accurately track your
self-loathing by seeing how many four
days you wasted watching anime jesus
[ __ ] christ I like doing with my life
and also track the anime you've watched
as well as it's like function it's still
a very important step however as that's
more higher you get from marking a shows
completed is the only gratification
you'll ever get from realizing you've
just wasted four hours watching 12
episodes of kawaii high school girl
[ __ ] again
getting to the actual season now the
most important period for any anime
season is the first three to four weeks
this is why lights called the gold rush
period everyone's watching everything
anything could be hype and every wanker
around you is in the race to find a next
gem of the season this is the time when
you can go absolutely mental the show's
you watch while being overly
enthusiastic just make sure you try to
support the industry as much as you can
you can do this by watching shows on
sites like crunchyroll Funimation and
daisuki when they are picked up by them
but recently Netflix and Amazon's anime
strike have been picking up shows as
well so if there's a show that's been
picked up by them that you want to watch
then [ __ ] kill me the first question
you may ask yourself is what new shows
should I pick up in this gold rush and
the correct answer is actually all of
them before guys can impress girls by
bragging about their careers or academic
achievements but these days you can do
pretty much the same thing by showing
off the slider you're currently watching
this if they're not impressed by that
however then you can really step it up
with that endless pit that never seems
to stop growing and just whip out your
plan to watch this after the gold rush
period we reach the important 3 episode
rule by this point you should have
gotten enough of a feel of a show to be
able to decide whether it's for you or
not and you can actually tell a lot
about the show and you
self as well by the episode you drop it
out if we drop a show at Episode one it
means the show is really bad drop at
Episode two and the shows and going
anywhere at Episode three is a standard
cutoff and dropping past episode four
then you're just a filthy we casual with
commitment issues you may find that you
pass it through episode point into
twenty hours worth of shows you want to
keep up with per week where you're
having trouble finding the time to keep
up with the more and it's starting to
affect your work or school so you have
to choose between anime or life
commitment and it's at this point you
need to ask yourself a very important
question do I really have the time every
week to let these stupid little things
ruin my life schedule and once you do
you can properly figure out okay how
many days work and lectures can I be
late for this week if for whatever even
however you can't find the time to keep
up with the show but don't want to drop
it the useful scheduling technique I
found really effective is by putting
that show and hold and forget him to
ever get back to it once you followed
enough anime seasons you may start to
notice some common themes so let's go
over some of these keep in mind and not
all of these are mutually exclusive and
a lot of shows can fit into several of
these categories the most obvious one is
the hype show receiving which is also
often called the hype train it's called
the hype train because once you gets on
the train stops you and everyone else
and talking about any other show until
the train is over you really see this
effect kick in about six weeks in when
everyone's watching something new it's
too early to discuss the upcoming season
and nobody in their right minds want to
talk to you about Kato the right answer
it's quite often that such a show is
hailed as the savior of anime as
thousands of fans for claim that anime
is saved for the seventh billion time
and you may wonder what constitutes of
saving anime in the first place or what
anime either needs saving from
sometimes you may be looking at a list
of new animes and come across a show
where you end up thinking what the hell
that someone accidentally put their
synopsis as a show title that's actually
called a light novel adaptation light
novels can be about anything limited
only by the things that an author can
imagine and that's the great thing about
knowing it's a light novel adaptation
it's knowing that the story is
definitely going to be set in a fancy
word or have a little sister in it you
may think that these are be the most
important shows of the season but this
isn't actually right as you start
hanging around the community you will
notice that anime fans have evolved
their own method of communication
through pictures of cute little anime
girls this is why the important thing to
look out for is that one girl every
season who you can stock up piles of
reaction shots for use when you're
interacting with other anime fans as the
only other communication method that's
proving to be as effective is Jojo I
mean once you've gotten into the groove
of things one day you may find yourself
watching a show and noticing that you've
grown attached to the characteristics of
a single female character and this is a
very important moment in your life so
hold it dearly because you've just been
drafted into a wall nobody really knows
how the best girl war started nobody
really knows how the war will end and
nobody really knows who wins or loses
but in the end it's all about winning or
losing
it's about salt remember that you are a
soldier on the front lines defending
your girl from shitty opinions and if
you don't do it who will there's no
reason we can't be civil with these
exchanges though humans are tribal
beings and we can still be understanding
even in disagreement for example I once
met a guy who claims that sin delays are
the cancer of this earth so I been open
in several human being that I am replies
by calling him a [ __ ]
there are several ways to support the
character you like one day you may just
retweet a gift that you like and the
next thing you know you're writing a 10
page essay my episode 12 of black I'm on
a guttering proved beyond a shadow of a
doubt - Jagger Hara is the gem that we
men do not yet deserve in this world
hypothetically speaking but what I do
also like to do is buy figurines because
that's light high yet when you complete
a purchase is just big enough to drown
out that nagging voice in the back of
your mind tells you that she'll never be
real there are however some girls who
you should never defend under any
circumstances girls like Sengoku from
the monogatari franchise Oh changing
girl from Eromanga sensei and amaru
churn for a Giga what happens if I'm
really attached to a character like
tomorrow what does that mean well
unfortunately that means you have a
disease called [ __ ] taste and there is
no known cure if you need to this you'll
probably come across a sequel that a lot
of people are excited about and you
haven't heard of it or you haven't
watched it have no fear as even if the
original show was popular as walls and
was the hype train of this time this
were not necessarily applied to the
Seekers this is known in anime as the
law of conservation of hype making that
more hype cannot be created past the
first season and entropy will cause it
to dissipate as a season increases in
iterations one important thing to keep
in mind is up watching past seasons the
catch up will just eat up more time that
he could be funny watching other shows
now so choose which one did you commit
to carefully for example I've heard
really good things about recreated this
season but I couldn't be bothered to
watch v-0 rely freezes right we've got
seen a line and you're we on ice to
catch up so I just set it on listening
to RiRi Biogen song for generation of
course there will inevitably be a few
shows nowadays that are targeted towards
the elusive female
anime fans and while you can normally
recognize use a mile away by looking for
fabulous food recipes of Nicholas men
with ABS you can grate cheese off of I
found these come in three basic
categories classy guys doing classy
things sporty guys doing sporty things
and ambiguous three homoerotic guys
doing ambiguously homoerotic things amy
erotically the show's don't always have
an undertone of homoeroticism around
them so you just have to look for
different levels of signs the most basic
level for example is if two guys make
eye contact with each other
then they're bombing each other in the
locker room obviously on the obscene of
the spectrum we have the super titty
high school psych lab there's pretty
much speaks to herself as the main
reason anyone would watch these shows is
because of the plots what is a term used
within the community to define the
overexposure of female boy part in a
sexualized way and is also occasionally
used to describe the writing and story
of an anime every so often though your
glance at the chart and see something
you won't believe a verb
you'll think it's an anomaly a mistake
by the site so you'll refresh the page
and look for other sources just to
confirm the information that's been
presented and as you slowly realize it's
true a bead of sweat will drop down your
eyes widen your heart starts racing as
its dormant the madman they did it they
actually [ __ ] did it
this shows can be running for more than
13 episodes and that's pretty much
everything you need to know about
getting into C's know anime you may be
listening to this guide wondering why
you'd ever want to get involved in
seasonal anime in the first place I mean
it just sounds like a massive time
sponge but trust me when I say it's all
worth it for that satisfying feeling
when you finish all your shows mark them
all as completed and as you're ready to
discuss everything you've just watched
you realize everyone's already moved on
to the next season you're enjoying the
video thank you very much this month -
Patrick Madsen Thrones melt
Jerrica tailgate Brown into moolah
Malcolm and everyone else the patron
publicist for me for this month and
making this video possible if all goes
as planned this video should be at 1 on
that ax I don't have any real updates
right now yeah that didn't work out way
too busy at the con but if you did want
the animes trash shot and atonement are
short those are still 7 think
they want to get them anyway I'm going
to enjoy Anime Expo right now which I am
hopefully doing at this very moment
because this is all pre-recorded so yeah
they'll be having fun teaching me at the
time in my life
thank you passkey guck